good morning believe nation today's
message is believed over to you Akon the
key really is to believe in what you're
doing I think you know a lot of people
invest in things they don't believe in
because they think it's gonna work but
you have you know you have to really
believe in it and the way to where
you're willing to put everything on the
line otherwise there's no purpose in
investment you know and you can't invest
ofhere say she say because you just
never really know what's gonna pop so
ultimately yeah exactly
you know what you want investment that
you feel that you would be even if it
didn't contain you put money to it and I
think that's always key you have to have
the passion for guys obviously you know
me this is an easy one for me it's right
here up on the wall believe and to add a
little bit more context to it I think
believe is something is easy to say but
can be hard to execute to me this is a
classic head versus heart discussion
when you first turn the business you
want to look at the numbers you want to
do the logical thing right you want to
think it out and you want to look at
what is selling well what is going to
pop where should I focus my time what
have other people done a bit successful
i it's the logical thing to do right
your brain takes over it says if I'm
going to certain business what business
would I start and what are the numbers
to back it up the challenge is if you
don't actually believe in that product
or service that you're selling it's
never gonna work
and this is the problem that most
entrepreneurs make too many
entrepreneurs start a business because
they think they're gonna make a lot of
money and it never takes off and it's
not because the ideas sucks is because
they never believed in the product or
service from the start and to believe in
your thing move into the heart side
instead of the head move the heart to
believe in your project is one of the
hardest thing to do ever because often
it comes when it's against what the head
is saying it's against a logical
rational way of thinking it takes a lot
of guts to say yeah I understand the
number see to do this and that everybody
doing that and this is where the markets
going this is even what our customers
are asking for or people are asking me
to do but I don't want to do that I want
to do this
I wanted this other thing this thing
that nobody's doing this scary thing the
thing that all the numbers say is a
terrible thing to do I want to go chase
that how do you have the courage and
confidence and conviction and passion to
go and do that that's the hard thing but
that's where the genius is that's where
the amazingness is that's where your
real business lies that's the thing that
most entrepreneurs don't do and so I
believe that you need to make the big
decisions with your heart you need to
love the big decisions in your life when
you decided about what career path you
go on when you're thinking about who
your life partner is going to be you
want to make decisions not with the head
that was the rationale well this person
looks good on paper and comes from the
right family and can get me into this
country or whatever it is you want to
make that decision with your heart and
then the little decisions you make with
your head I make these videos because I
love them I would make these videos even
if nobody was paying attention to them
because I need them for me because it
fuels me because I love doing it I look
forward to filming these videos I look
forward to watch my own channel I think
I have the best channel on YouTube for
me in my personal opinion but I need
this for myself but I would do it
regardless and then the head can take
over with the smaller decisions like how
do I name this video how do I add tags
in the description and playlists and all
the little things to make that big dream
happen but it has to start with the
heart it has to start with something
that you are so passionate about that
you believe it so much that you are
going to will it into existence even if
nobody else believes in you you got me
all excited this morning but we're
talking about belief it's on the wall
what do you expect so the question today
is do you deeply truly meaningful II
passionately my voice is cracking
believe in what you are doing do you
have the same level of excitement that
is
coming out here that's what I want to
know leave in the comments below and I
will join in the discussion
thank you so much for watching have an
amazing day continue to believe and I'll
see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot I've been stressing